if I have a square 95 a squared that is
1 centimeter by 1 centimeter so you can
draw this along with me once enemy but
once you send me up it's area is 1 semi
not sweat right and if I have a cube
that is 1 centimeter by 1 centimeter by
1 centimeter right it's volume is 1
centimeter cubed 1 cubic centimeter okay
but we learnt about like converting
between different units before just in
terms of length right but when you move
into area involve you there are tricks
to watch out for
right so for instance if I now draw for
myself a new square but not 1 centimeter
by 1 centimeter
let's do it one meter by one meter okay
so I'm going to ask two things firstly
just how are you saying what's the area
of this thing what is the area of this
square yep what makes we're perfect okay
it's one meter square but suppose I
would actually like some more fine
measurements suppose I want to measure
this bigger square in terms of square
centimeters right well how many
centimeters are there in a mean are how
many centimetres even in yeah atoms
there's a hundred a hundred centimeters
in a meter okay
hundred centimeters in a meter now if
that's the case a hundred centimeters
equals one meter
it would seem natural it would seem
intuitive to say well therefore if
that's one meter square it'll be a
hundred centimeters squared right 1 100
100 but something's going wrong what's
going wrong who can try and articulate
it what's gone
yeah yeah very good it's about the units
right sir let's come back to where this
area is this is really one meet up by
one meter okay see that and now I can
take advantage of this so this is each
one of them is a hundred therefore 100
right because I properly changed my
units now and they were two of them so I
changed both okay and now you can see
it's 100 centimeter square at all right
it's actually 100 500 which is ten
thousand ten thousand it's four zeros
okay now exactly the same thing happens
for voice except even more so okay I
just need a bit more space
okay so if we say if we now say okay one
cubic metre one cubic metre
the volume is one again there's a bit of
a temptation to say oh it's okay
meeting in the centimeters just one to a
hundred right should be 100 cubic
centimeters but we're not even close how
should I translate it hash that convert
it properly
yeah yeah yeah partly because like the
unity I taught here it makes these feel
bigger than they are sometimes so
anybody said yeah Rachel okay I'm gonna
write that down here which is exactly
right I'm gonna put one line extra
before that cuz where did these 300s
come from yeah good they came from a
meter by Amina
bond Amina that's you can even see where
the three one meters are right there's
an up-down and left-right in a back and
forth okay
so therefore how many zeros do I have
I've got six zeros right one
three four five six that's a million
cubic centimeters that's a lot that's a
lot okay
but really what that reflects is well
think about it guys
it's a box right it's a box and it is
well I'm actually going to draw it here
I can just try and do this I think here
is one meter this way this way because
I've just got nothing sort of destroy
okay so this one meter by one meter
right and to make the cube I need the
one meter to come out of the board right
so I've got a box that's this big it's
huge right and you know a cubic
centimeter these things are really small
look you've got one on your page right
you've got that one that's to scale on
your page how many of those things would
fit in my box answer a million if you
packed it in properly I suppose okay